[Musica]
non è necessario che io faccia ste
cagate prima di partire da tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti avessero video sono tali j
procede da una calmata sta canzone per
l'amor di dio ed oggi siamo su the
breakfast club ragazzi che sarebbe
dovrebbe essere una roba tipo aim brand
ma non è proprio ai e brad solo le 7 56
mancano 4 minuti grazie a selezione di
oggetti che si spostano è la madonna
posso animare qualsiasi oggetto anni
farmi animare il coltello
hai mai visto shining fatto merda dai
[ __ ] tosto salta ma come s'è
suicidato cazzo
prima cosa allora il tosto questo lo
prendo e lo metto sul piatto giusto vita
è più facile da comandare questo
libretto è rimasto tritto con quale
criterio fisico a me non importa
beh adesso che ci sono questi due cose
che si ingrossano passiamo alla fase
successiva il burro esattore di spalmare
il burro non sulla tovaglia non sulla
tovaglia sul pane no
porca [ __ ] è difficile che si trova
oggi ok creando un toast zio non stai
creando lo shuttle della nasa
ok no no no no dai non devi farti la
forchetta devi imburrare bravo trio al
cazzo devo mettere gli altri e va beh ma
mica non lo farò mai
c'è prima delle 8 ci metterò un anno e
mezzo ma non riesco neanche a portarli
sopra come faccio devo creare una
scaletta qualcuno minto steel toast ok
ho creato questa sorta di ponte per far
passare i toast e non so se funziona no
sole 8 li mortacci tua come faccio a
mandare un toast sopra al tostapane non
ci arriva neanche il came avea era così
potente zio
il burro lo devi togliere dagli toglilo
tanto non serve un cazzo
ok prova usarlo come ponte vedere se
sale funziona funziona
minchia quanto sono un genio non a
quello l'hai già tostato quella lei
blige athos cazzo non è che si bruciano
non avranno fatto che quello che non
doveva costare 6 costando se però stai
calmo vai vai vai vai bravissimo però se
che mancano tre minuti non ce la faccio
mai
sempre con porca eva [ __ ] ma che
cosa c'è nel cervello perché non ci sale
se non metti il ponte [ __ ]
ho trovato l'unico modo per portare la
roba un genio non si bravissimo bravi
quanto ti adoro sa che è quello è uno
zio devi spostare spostare e non si
muove dai mi si è incastrato il toast
vai su vai su dai che ce la fai il bravo
zio bravissimo sia durata 4 4 ma ne
mancano due amiche ce la fai manca mi
manca un minuto nsofor mai però forse sì
scp ci mettono impegno sistemi ci
mettono impegno si vai vai vai vai sali
salita quella già finito sul piatto che
culo
hi fi uno sforzo nella tua inutile vita
da toast di merda dai dai dai dai dai
dai dai dai dai che michalis allontana
il burro maledizione 2
tra [ __ ] di jack e botte che dal
burro 34 hanno fatti è 4 è già tanto 4
c'è dio mio 4 sono quattro non ce la
faccio a farne 6 mangi di me non
stamattina va bene sei sono impossibili
ragazzi impossibili io nella vita reale
non ce la faccio a farne neanche uno in
tre minuti figurati 6 mortacci tua stai
fermo per che cosa sta impostando che ce
la fai a star fermo vai vai vai è giusto
devi entrare frate entra entra entra io
mio quanto può essere difficile sto
gioco da da 1 milione entra cristo o
minchiam anno e mezzo per posta su
schivo
cosa è successo cosa vuoi ma posso usare
anche il fiore per farli salire forse
forse sono riuscito a trovare la
situazione perfetta
minchia che scala ho fatto fantastico
così c'è la scala perfetta ce la posso
fare per mezz'ora per pasta roba non
avete idea
quando di preciso dove ammazzati la
famiglia ok fosso trovato un altro modo
ancora amico in quanti modi sto trovando
regala prefetto perfetto per no devi
stare sopra devi stare so io ok ok ok ok
perfetto piano entra o che non me lo far
cadere giù perché perfetto se mi cade
giù cambio giuro ok adesso che devi
uscire esci cristo ok da che manca un
minuto ce la posso fare non troverò mai
non ce la farò mai più a rifare quello
che ho fatto adesso e quindi devo
muovermi
vai vai vai meglio dei freni l'altro
veloce manca un minuto ci posso fare se
se questo entra e quello non cade ce la
faccio ok [ __ ] sì sì sì sì sì no no
no no devi salire
devi salire si è tolta la forchetta
cristo s'è tolta la forchetta nel
momento sbagliato ma io non ci voglio
credere se tota vai vai vai vai vai sali
christian sale dai sì sì sì sì sì io non
ci credo prendi il suo coltello di merda
ma quanto mancano trenta secondi come
hai fatto a finire sotto il piatto come
hai fatto ti ammazzerei la famiglia in
tre strati diversi tra diversi dai
ragazzi passiamo al secondo episodio
troverò chi ha fatto sto cazzo di gioco
lo troverò l'ammazzo è perfetto
pensa che il suicidio neanche in
dragonball immagini v ho visto delle
botte cosiddette di partire in avanti e
non mi pare non mi fa scherzi e manca
uno non ci posso credere
due minuti in un minuto ne ho fatti tre
commettete che non riesco per qualche
motivo strano si deve essere sempre
qualcosa che non va comunque non so cade
un meteorite ce la fai entrare cristo
che non con minuto ce la fai a dio
potevo giocare anche mario grillo
l'ultimo toste cadu ma io lo sapevano
detto cosa avevo detto prima ci sarà
qualcosa che succederà che non mi farà
vincere sapevo io lo sapevo
guardatelo messo bene la forchetta lega
niente stavo scherzando non ti muovere
stai fermo ok come che questo come ha
fatta rimane così se non lo tenevo
ragazzi andava a genio su saturno sto
cazzo di toto due minuti per testarne
una imburrare lì tutti bravo io ti
ringrazio
ma quanto lontano va bene va bene va
bene così ce li ho tutti e sei
manca un minuto e mezzo forza ragazzi
non ce la farò mai più a tornare qui e
se non ce la faccio perso 17 lo
scommesse se ci riescono e rega cazzo
dai due ai dai dai dai manco minuto
qualche minuto la ce4 cristo che è certo
5 maggio 1 20 secondi veloce
dai dai un'arca 1 dopo anni non ci credo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora io non so cucinare non so
fancazzo ma porca [ __ ] dei toast ho
sudato per fare dei fottuti tosto ero
più contento ne farei un prete lo giuro
minchia lega mai più mai più una roba
del genere è stato orribile ha c'è anche
la parte ii anno ecco fiennes un dato
non l'avrei fatto uguale ragazzi non vi
preoccupate
bastava farmi chiudere non ne posso più
che gioco di un gioco di merda che cosa
vado a trovare alle volte lo so solo io
ragazzi spero che vide vi sia piaciuto
spero che viaggio imparato come fare dei
costi perché lo zio fare insegna non
fate domande su questo video non sono
anche perché non sono io non so niente
della vita non so niente
[ __ ] spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come se tu sei video è piaciuta
da un commento mi piace anche a pace di
facebook e con il video trattare le
iscrizioni central city sky ci vediamo
al prossimo video ragazzi ricordatevi
kate hostess non sono cattivi sono io
che non so fancazzo però vabbè